les auteurs ou bien la compétition rien
ne lui fait peur
treize mille sauts à son actif vainqueur
du dernier championnat du monde au
classement général cédric dégâts rios
votent à nouveau briller aux
championnats du monde et non pas qu on a
gagné on ne peut plus arriver deuxième
la défaite c'est une fois qu'on a une
fois qu'on a gagné on doit gagner parce
que deuxième ça va pas là on commence à
avoir à faire des bonds des bons des
bonbonnes ont atteint des graines de
bons sauts donc ouais je pense que d'ici
un mois et demi on devra avoir devrait
être sur des sauts de niveau mondial
à 28 ans nicholas gallo a déjà goûté aux
joies de la coupe du monde et du
championnat de france ses premiers
mondiaux
il les prépare depuis deux ans j'ai
suivi l'équipe en fait pendant leurs
entraînements et on met le coach
philippe cousin m'a invité à la gloire
du sud mais j'ai la chance d'être
multiplié avec les meilleurs du monde
exc c'est super on apprend on apprend
encore plus vite on m'apprend beaucoup
mieux c'est une chanson
météo capricieuse stage hivernal à
l'étranger annulé pour cause de pandémie
l'équipe de france de pilotage sous
voile a dû écourter sa préparation
il en faut plus pour inquiéter son
entraîneur c'est quand même les athlètes
de haut niveau qui s'entraîne depuis
trois quatre ans dans la discipline pour
préparer les championnats du monde donc
je le sens bien je pense qu'on en bas on
va faire un podium - titre au prochain
championnat sans souci pour ces mondiaux
les ambitions tricolores s'affichant
détour ramener au moins une médaille
d'or de russie